this is a production of Cornell
University
great good afternoon I'm Katherine Bohr
I'm Dean of the College of Agriculture
and life sciences here at Cornell
University and it's truly my honor to
welcome you all here this afternoon and
thank you very much for joining us for
today's industrial hemp summit it's
truly a pleasure for me to welcome New
York State Department agriculture and
markets Commissioner Richard ball
sitting here on my left and Commissioner
ball has been just a real champion for
our state's agricultural industries and
for the research that's so essential for
keeping our industries competitive in
today's marketplace I'm also grateful to
be joined this afternoon by
Assemblywoman Donna Lupardo also here at
the front table and earlier this morning
also a champion for this initiative
Senator Tom O'Mara was with us this
morning now today's summit is an
opportunity for Cornell experts for
experts from other universities here in
New York State for industry members to
share their knowledge and to share their
experience on industrial hemp potential
impact on the economy here in New York
State the conversations that we are
having today are intended to help build
momentum around government Governor
Cuomo's vision for expanding industrial
hemp production here in New York and as
some of you heard me say this morning we
do have tremendous potential here in New
York State for the production of
industrial hemp which really has not
been grown here for decades now if
efficiently and and economically grown
an emphasis on that efficiently and
economically grown industrial hemp could
be used to launch a wide range of New
York made goods that could include
things like healthy hemp seed oils
building insulation animal bedding novel
medicinal products however because hemp
has not been grown commercially here in
our state for so long a great deal of
research and preparation lies ahead of
all of us and this is where Cornell
University and our SUNY partners come in
and and we have roles to play here for
example our plant BRE
have the knowledge and the experience to
advance hemp breeding and to test a
range of varieties for performance here
in our state they can help determine the
best growing practices for hemp here in
New York and where and when and under
what conditions it will flourish our
college and our SUNY partners are
committed to providing sustainable
improvement in the lives of people here
in New York State through our research
through our teaching and through our
outreach and we're particularly pleased
to work in concert specifically with our
SUNY partners our State University of
New York system partners from SUNY
Morrisville the new School of Pharmacy
at Binghamton University and our
Sullivan Community College as well now
we are committed we are committed to
exploring New York's capacity to grow
industrial hemp profitably and to take
advantage of new markets and through
such strategies we can help facilitate
rural economic agricultural development
throughout our state today's summit
really is only the beginning of what I
hope will be a very successful venture
for our state so thank you again for
joining us today
to learn more about this emerging
industry and how we can collectively
help it grow and so now for this
afternoon I would like to introduce our
first speaker and that's New York State
Department of Agriculture and markets
Commissioner Richard ball Commissioner
ball began his career in agriculture as
a farm worker at a vegetable farm in
Rhode Island when he was 18 years old he
has been the owner and the operator for
this couple years ago maybe he's been
the owner and the operator of Schoharie
Valley Farms in Schoharie New York for
the last 20 years and that is a 200-acre
farm that produces a wide range of
vegetable crops and small fruits and
greenhouse crops he has held a number of
very important positions with
agriculture and community organizations
including the New York State vegetable
Growers Association he was vice
president and as well with New York Farm
Bureau Board of Directors a member of
executive committee member of audit
committee chairman of Labor Committee
now he has served as the Commissioner of
New York State Department of Agriculture
and markets since 2014 and I've been
truly honored to partner with him on
critically important initiatives that
he's launched from the newly
reinvigorated Council on hunger and food
policy to The Milk Marketing Advisory
Council and we collectively strive to
ensure that the Commissioner can count
on all of our SUNY schools to step up to
the plate to assist the state and our
agricultural communities please join me
in welcoming Commissioner Richard ball
that was a nice way of saying you got an
overdressed farmer in front of you right
really great to be here it's great to
see the crowd has gotten kind of
energized a little bigger there's a lot
of interest in this subject and thank
you so much Dean we had an awesome
discussion this morning we had the
Lieutenant Governor here and some of
your elected representatives and some of
them still here but we had a great
discussion a great summary we looked at
where the industry is now we looked at
what we've done so far we looked at our
potential and we looked at where the
opportunities for the state to intersect
and help grow it and I think we're
pretty much all on the same page and to
kind of summarize that I won't talk
anymore but I would direct your
attention once again to the to the
screen we showed a video this morning
we're going to show it again because we
have a number of new people and because
we like the video so if you would direct
your attention to the thousands of
years-- industrial hemp has been a
valuable and versatile crop once a top
commodity on American farms production
was driven out by other emerging
industries and eventually the federal
government made it illegal to grow until
now recognizing its vast potential the
federal farm bill allowed States to
launch pilot programs for industrial
hemp research and in 2015 Governor Cuomo
announced a bold plan to put the Empire
State at the forefront of the country's
hemp provided with the type of
legislative action that Governor Cuomo
has led with with Albany
it's making a real difference partnering
with SUNY Morrisville JD farms in
Madison County harvested New York's
first industrial hemp crop in decades
Cornell University wasn't far behind it
was made possible through Governor
Cuomo's industrial hemp research pilot
program allowing up to ten permits to
grow and research hemp as an
agricultural commodity study nitrogen
content Mesilla we studied seeding rates
New York is abundant in water abundant
and arable land and for us this crop
made a lot of sense
hemp research is now expanding across
the state I think hemp is not only a
great opportunity for diversification on
the ground but it could lead to a lot of
great job and manufacturing
opportunities that we've lost sort of
today to globalization hemp and
marijuana may look similar but make no
mistake these plants have a significant
difference I think the major thing for
people to realize is that industrial
hemp is not marijuana even though it
looks like it THC is the mind-altering
drug and in marijuana and industrial
half have very very low levels of that
generations of innovators have pioneered
new markets for this dynamic crop using
every part of the plant to drive growth
in vital industries and boost the
profitability of the agricultural sector
today the US retail market for
industrial hemp is nearly six hundred
million dollars and makes a good
insulation as well as wallboard for
buildings will be useful for automobiles
pressboard and furniture bags and
biodegradable packaging material so
shampoos cosmetic products you shell
hemp seeds themselves or tasty and
they're a great superfood now with the
support of the state legislature
Governor Cuomo is taking the program to
the next level removing the cap on the
number of permits for hemp research
supporting unprecedented exploration of
the crops viability and encouraging New
York's best and brightest to discover
and rediscover hemp potential and as we
have more opportunity to do research I
think we can just make it a better crop
and a more economical crop across the
board we could bring lots of industry
back to New York State put a lot of
people back to work
Shep is really an industrial crop it
should just regain its rightful place in
the American agricultural landscape the
global demand for industrial hemp is
growing and here in New York the
possibilities are endless possibilities
are endless you know one of the words
that the Dean and I'd like to share with
each other quite a bit is collaboration
we talked about that a little bit
earlier but I think when we collaborate
and we have our partners here in the
room and we have our partners on the
same page who can be against this I like
our I like our chances here
the governor is very much committed to
this idea he's excited about hemp and we
talked about in our regular basis so
this is I just want to say from the
state standpoint we're committed to
staying with this and doing the things
that we need to do so there's a vision
behind all of this
there's a very practical side of it
today's summit is even though we've been
working at this many of you for a long
time certainly many of us at the state
level for a couple of years now coming
up with the ideas and doing the
necessary work to get it over the hump
we're not done yet there's more to do in
this summit is really just the beginning
so excited to be here the Lieutenant
Governor when we got done with our
session this morning we had a good
conversation with a number of our
partners we heard some needs
we heard some things that needed to to
be done in order of us for us to take
those next steps going forward and I'm
just going to summarize for you now some
of the deliverables from this morning
session that are underway as you know
the first legislation which was
sponsored by my colleague here to the
left it helped us get started and
allowed the Department
to designate some areas attached to
research institutions to begin to do
some work on hemp in New York State
well we've issued the first ever
research permits to private farms and
businesses and previously that pilot
program was limited to the research
institutions but at the governor's
direction we've expanded the pilot to
include private entities so six of those
private farms and businesses were issued
permits bring the total the total number
of hemp research sites across the state
to ten so we've added 21st century hemp
and our RIT in Rochester we've added
Cavallaro farms in Goshen New York once
again JD farms in eat in New York old
Mud Creek farm in Hudson New York the
plant science labs in Buffalo and
pre-process in ellsberg New York a
couple of other things of note that we
heard from our partners this morning
going forward we're going to seek DEA
permit allowing businesses to import
seed and establish a seed distribution
site for international imports we heard
about the importance of C importing seed
is central to research in New York State
and in addition to that we are seeking a
US Drug Enforcement Agency permit to
import the seed so the New York State
Department of Ag and markets will
advocate to ease the federal
requirements to acquire hemp seed so
that will be making the federal efforts
as well but in the meantime we will hold
the permit at the Department happy to
announce that we're going to award
$400,000 to Cornell University to
continue to expand the research we heard
that loud and clear
the researchers at Cornell's AG
Experiment Station in Geneva are going
to explore the best practices for
growing varieties the best varieties of
them the different soil types the
various locations around the state we've
got a lot of catching up to do
culturally if we're going to be
successful with this crop and the
Experiment Station will also assess hemp
seed quality for germination and weed
contamination so thank you for that
we're going to establish a hemp
technical
team the lieutenant governor talked
about this to support optimal growing
and processing of hemp
the state will establish a hemp
technical team consisting of our
department in Ag and markets of liaison
they're three Cornell Cooperative
Extension partners educators in the
field so we need to stay on the same
page as we go forward we're going to
increase our testing capacity at the
department we heard about that this
morning as a need the department will
apply for a permit to test industrial
hemp for THC which is an important part
of the process obviously this additional
lab capacity will help ensure that New
York State emceed and other products are
accepted in other states testing will
also provide protection to the
department that growers the researchers
that the crops meet the acceptable THC
level we're gonna create a working group
on top of the technical team a working
group to stay on the same page again to
support industry development it will
include academic partners key industry
members other state agencies to
strengthen the hemp industry in New York
State the working group will help build
relationships share information and best
management practices regulatory
requirements and as we go forward
identify the research needs that come up
we're gonna engage stakeholders and
program development so we're all
partners in this we'll seek input from
farmers researchers industry leaders
will look to revise the pilot program as
we need to the regulations and the
program requirements and in addition
we'll propose changes to minimize the
oversight of the research done by the
educational institutions as it's
appropriate and I think this is clearly
very important point to make here
advocate for the federal policies to
boost the industry we're still
restricted we still have this cloud
hanging over our head and over this
industry but the governor has an office
in Washington DC they're very active
they're on the same page with you and
with us they have influence with the
Congress down there for me at the
Department of Agriculture and at our
other agencies in the state we all have
national relationships with other
commissioners secretaries and directors
and that organization will also advocate
and we'll work through those channels as
well to help advance what we know to be
the right direction to go in so I think
I'm encouraged I'm encouraged at the
national level I'm encouraged certainly
here at the state level I think as you
go through this afternoon you will see
the quality of program the quality of
people involved in here and you should
be encouraged as well with that let me
introduce our partner and Assemblymember
downlo Pardo who has sent me more emails
in the last year than I've got from any
other single source I think she's very
focused she's very passionate she cares
a great deal about her people her farms
her agriculture here in New York State
and this mission so with that thank you
she's never given me that email address
that was your first problem well hi
everyone it's really very nice of you to
all be here today and you share I'm sure
aren't interested passion in this new
exciting crop industrial hemp you know
many of us I'm sure in the room are old
enough to have you know lamented for a
very very long time that this crop was
something we could not grow and as I
became more familiar with the potential
of this crop it was really unacceptable
to be honest with you that we had a
consumer demand for products people were
purchasing products people were
manufacturing products with imported
materials and it didn't make any sense
to me whatsoever that we weren't able to
afford our farmers that opportunity and
to give manufacturers homegrown local
product and when the farm bill came
along which allowed New York State to
become a place where we could do pilot
research senator O'Mara and I jumped all
over it and I'm you know it was a bit of
a stretch to people we had to go one by
one with the vote ham why industrial
hemp sheet and explained to people right
off the bat that it was not marijuana it
was a cousin it was this it was that and
they finally understood especially for
places like upstate New York the
enormous economic potential for not only
farmers but for manufacturers I come
from Endicott New York and represent
Endicott and Binghamton area which was
all about shoes and computers it was a
manufacturing town so many places are as
well and to get the economic developers
to have this come to clarity for them
that this isn't just about growing a
crop this is about producing goods and
services but making goods again in New
York State and I think that's what
really began to turn people around about
this the following year the farm bill
gave us another opportunity to not only
research this crop but to also market it
transport it process it and sell it if
it were not for that particular bill all
the research crops would have had to
have been destroyed which would be a
terrible thing because the forty acres
of beautiful hemp that you're seeing and
depicted in this logo behind us that JD
farms was just a spectacular thing to
see and smells pretty good too by the
way let's say and so we are now able to
to take advantage full advantage of what
they have allowed we've stocked this at
the federal level whatever they've
allowed we've come right behind it
Senator Rand Paul and Mitch McConnell
are the sponsors of these bills and some
of our own senator senator Gillibrand
are sponsors of the industrial hemp
farming act you know while they are
trying to figure this out in Washington
New York State is positioning itself to
be very competitive an all manner of
hemp whether it's in the pharmaceutical
nutraceutical textiles of various food
and other other products that are
already in the works it's very exciting
so when the federal government does
relax this which will make it a little
bit easier for us we will have the
Northeast pretty much sewed up as far as
I can tell and all of you who are in the
room who expecting to get involved in
this
I think will be very pleased with
outcome commissioner a ball mentioned
some of the fabulous developments at the
state level we're very lucky that the
state is willing to really come to
assist on the de a seed certification a
seed acquisition issue and all the rest
of these considerations with research
dollars becoming behind it and trying to
make it easier for those of you who have
been involved in the craft beverage
industry once the state got its head
wrapped around making it easier for
craft beverages you have seen the
results and I can tell you without a
shadow of a doubt that this is the next
thing that the governor and team are
putting their full force and focus
behind it's truly a very exciting time
for those of us who've long long wish
that Hamm could be receiving its due so
what I want to just say in closing is
that just to get everybody on the same
page we had 10 research licenses as part
of the original program and those have
all been filled what is about to happen
now as part of the recent budget is
going again the Commissioner mentioned
they're going to be unlimited licenses
available but regs have to be
established for that so we're a little
we're a little behind for this growing
season but I would fully expect and I
hope correct me if I'm wrong the 2018
will very likely be the year when we can
see a much larger build-out among
farmers who are interested it's going to
be critical however that those farmers
understand the supply chain and are
going to be growing for a particular
market so they're not just randomly
growing some random cultivar they're
going to be growing from a particular
market and that market is going to have
processing available and we have in the
mix proposals right now to do hubs in
the area of whether it be on CBD oil or
in fiber so in 2018 you may very well be
in a position to have a marriage with a
particular company that wants a certain
type of strain and you may have a
processor in the mix so it's all
seamless with the assistance from the
state
so thanks for your patience over these
years and decades for some of us who
have cared about this plant our time has
finally come and I'm absolutely
delighted to be part of it and happy to
to play whatever role I need to in the
future thank you this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell edu